so one of my all-time favorite guests to
have on the show is my friend Adam pally
I'm sure you know him from shows like
happy endings and the Mindy project I
never know what he's gonna say he loves
breaking my balls and we have a good
time together
he kind of wrecks the show but in the
good way you know I mean like Letterman
had Bill Murray
I have Adam pally and I recently got to
talk to him again it was so much fun we
actually had to split it into two acts
so please check out my conversation with
the hilarious Adam pally so there's no
more audience any more for you huh they
didn't trust us with the audience yeah
and they've like everything so much
smaller well we're on the way out what
number interview mine created because
your voices wrap I'm so happy to welcome
back to the show one of my favorite
people and one of the funniest people I
know Adam pally oh thanks I feel the
same way about you do you yeah my dad's
here your dad is here yeah why um why'd
I bring my dad yeah well cuz he's in
town and I didn't know what else to do
with him
at a certain point dad's just become
like you know they're like pets zoo zoo
it yeah if like I am doing bay yeah like
you you stay here I'm going in for ice
cream this is the man that taught you
how to read oh yeah I live essentially
wait yeah here dad yeah my dad's like 58
so he's young and mobile and I'm still
like don't move don't wander off like we
went to the farmers market the other day
and I I was with my son and I was like
holding my son I was like I'm gonna go
just run and get he needs a balloon I'm
gonna go run and get him and I went to
get a balloon and then I realized that
my dad was holding my wallet so I turned
around gone he had like seen a butterfly
or something and like wandered off and I
like was like looking and then I finally
saw the back of his head like a 10-4
looking at like gyros he's like Adam you
know they have meat here I'm like uh
with freaking wallet
don't buy any loose meat you can't spell
dad without a TD that's what I said yeah
what who can't spell dad without a TD
are you trying to thank you are you
trying to think about it D no I got the
joke I feel bad for all these people I
have to work with you all that like the
horrible thing is like this is a pretty
plum gig for like um writers and and the
sound people and like the camera feels
like pretty decent and then once they
start having a deal with you every day
they're like oh I'll go out in the heat
I'll like work Breaking Bad sure at this
point I feel like the camera people
would would rather ride a sybian
you're like having like have bababooey
talk to them though because if you can't
[ __ ] dad or not a TD exactly like a
hundred percent be government well
that's what's scary see I tell did dad a
TD joke and it does badly that's just
for me you tell a bad joke you have to
think about your son like Babu yeah yeah
wanting a can of beans
yeah well you should think about that
next time you throw out a joke like that
maybe you should be thinking about stuff
like that no one will breed with me yeah
you're talking as if it's like carefree
and everything's gold for you I can't
hit a false no only thing I throw out
just seems to work you know and I don't
think about Oh cut me down